how are they going to feel say you're a
female conservative host there which
they have a few you're popping in a
bathroom and a guy walks in How's that
gonna go down there if they thought this
through has Fox News considered maybe
leaving New York
they should they should I mean listen
after the Tucker thing they've got
bigger problems I mean I I don't I'm not
sure a lot a lot of people linked it but
this is a great let me can I read
something it's quick I promise I hear
people read stuff but this was someone
gave this up to Breitbart and this kind
of explains it all they said uh because
this is kind of accurate they're talking
about why me and me and Tucker weren't
resigned and some source told them this
is from a map oil piece that uh bongino
and Carlson once Source said were
considered the two most likely to say
you to management
degrees right here a network Insider
said adding that bongino gave zero
and Tucker gave even less